why don't we uh take the first question
here uh
zack sg
has uh explained why ubi socialism is
bad by the way shout out matt and jordy
look at it i already got the comments up
on a uh on a visual pulling it up on the
screen pretty damn good right uh explain
why ubi socialism is bad so take out
socialism for a second just ubi ubi use
uh universal basic income it's the whole
idea that the government is going to
hand out money directly to people and
will replace their uh their salaries now
the first thing is just the incentive
system if we want to have a productive
society we need to have an incentive
system that says go produce things and
then you get value if the government
just sends you checks and you can just
sit back and chill on your lazy boy
recliner
what are you producing what value did
you create for us as a society or as an
economy if you don't create value but
you still get paid now you're
incentivized to do nothing you don't
have to do anything there's no incentive
and so naturally you throw off the
incentives and it will likely lead to a
very unproductive economy in society and
naturally will end up having very
long-term negative impact the second
thing is ubi is one of the most
inflationary things we could do we just
saw a version of it where they're
handing out 200
and the net result was we got 8.5
inflation if they were to turn around
and say every american every single one
of you we got you don't worry we're
politicians we're here to save you we're
going to hand out checks every month you
get a thousand dollars
uh
that's gonna be bad what is inflate
you're gonna go to then 15 20 25
no they'll manipulate the basket they'll
tell you it's only eight and a half
percent but naturally what's going to
happen is i'll give you a thousand
dollars a month but i'll screw you with
inflation
it is a horrible idea you cannot hand
out free money to people for doing
nothing because you throw off the
incentive system and you also drive
inflation through the roof so that's
first one
second thoughts on negative gdp we just
talked about that what i would say there
uh is that the negative gdp ends up
being uh one just hilarious that the
economist can be off so bad and keep
their jobs uh two the economy
contracting not good uh we will i
believe get two quarters straight of of
contraction of the economy uh but i
think the the more important thing is
that we're getting the negative gdp
growth with the inflation
so historically what you've thought
about is if you're a central banker okay
i can let inflation run hot or i can
raise interest rates and probably throw
us into a recession inflation recession
inflation recession pick your poison
but now what we've done is nope we get
both
that's not a good situation to be in so
i think that's the big takeaway from
this is that we're getting the negative
gdp growth with the inflation and this
is after the central bank put us down to
zero percent interest rates and we sent
about seven trillion dollars into the
economy well
if we do all that manipulation all that
propping up
we're going to need bigger and bigger
hits of stimulus in the future to get
more growth we have to grow
and the only way to do that is we're
going to go from what used to be
hundreds of billions of dollars in
stimulus packages to now recent in
recent two years was trillions of
dollars eventually we're going to start
seeing 10 plus trillion dollar stimulus
packages that's right right now what's
today today is april 29th 2022 i'm
calling it in the next 10 years we will
see 10 trillion dollar stimulus packages
why because they have to
it's like a drug addict the more that
somebody's addicted to drugs they need
more and more of the drug to get that
same high and as they get a bigger and
bigger high eventually they overdose
because they take too much of the drug
well that's eventually what happens to
an economy as well we've seen this over
and over and over again in history now
it's just the time that it seems like
it's coming to fruition
uh
fox asking do you think bitcoin is going
to drop by over 30
this year uh i believe that bitcoin is
already down uh pretty significantly
this year let's see real quick if we
look at the year-to-date chart of
bitcoin bitcoin was trading at about 46
uh thousand dollars to start the year
today it's down uh about 39 000 so let's
call it that it's down seven thousand
dollars or so as you all know i'm not a
genius so let me go to uh the uh the
calculator 47
or i'm sorry 7 divided by 46
is uh it's already down 15
so we're halfway there uh and in order
for it to go down uh even more have to
get down to about 31
000 give or take and it already touched
down around 33.34 so in some way dropped
you know 25 plus percent uh already this
year at some point uh the question is
just where does it end the year and uh
my guess is that by the end of the year
uh there'll be lots of volatility along
the way but they're going to get back
into
easing of monetary and fiscal policy and
if they do that bitcoin will be a great
beneficiary of it because of the
volatility
tim barnes asking the next country to
have bitcoin as legal tender
if you think of what countries are most
likely to adopt bitcoin is legal tender
it is countries that need the most help
so the united states is likely to be one
of the last countries to adopt bitcoin's
legal tender because the us dollar works
pretty well if i go to the bank it gives
me my money if i go and i spend my
dollar it usually has about the same
value that it had yesterday and so
naturally the places that have somewhat
stable or strong currencies are not
going to be incentivized to do this but
the countries that do need to have some
sort of new currency they are
incentivized to do it el salvador is a
great example it's a dollarized nation
they have no uh internal or sovereign
currency they use the us dollar so for
them to do it they're not worried about
the dollar or hurting the dollar in the
confidence game because it's not their
currency so it made sense for them to do
it so it could be another dollarized
nation to go ahead and do it also it
could be somebody where their currency
is completely failed uh my guess though
is the dollarized nations are going to
see that this is an opportunity
to if you can't control the currency
yourself that your citizens are using
the next best thing is to use a currency
that no one controls and that's where
bitcoin i think comes in
then if we take a look uh who is this uh
metahuman uh the question is though
won't the student loan debt crisis
become like the mortgage crisis because
they clearly can't pay that back
government bailout is inevitable how do
we respond uh it's potentially um the
the
answer here though i think it just ends
up being that student loans uh aren't
the government's problem right like at
the end of the day what you end up
seeing is that individuals are going to
have to deal with this but the
difference between student loans and the
mortgage crisis the mortgage crisis
drove prices of homes up and then there
was a massive crash and there were
investors betting on the continuation of
home prices going up or the failure of
home prices and so that's where you
really got it the reason why the
mortgage crisis led to all sorts of
financial issues is because all these
banks had massive exposure to the
mortgage market and ended up being a
house of cards and it fell apart and
then the banks were literally brought to
their knees and almost failed some of
them did fail uh and ended up having
huge issues student loan market while
large is nowhere near as financialized
as the mortgage market was and so i
don't think that you would have the same
kind of systemic issues as you would
have with the mortgage market
uh let's do um we'll do one more
uh
[Applause]
let's say
uh what are you gonna do differently in
your personal portfolio diamond hand or
sell in may walk away and come back q3
uh i don't sell one of the biggest
lessons that i've learned in investing
is uh i try my hardest not to sell
things every once in a while for
liquidity management or something i've
got to sell an investment here or there
uh but it's never because uh i change my
mind really in terms of the investment
uh itself and its future prospects for
the most part uh my strategy is to buy
assets and then hold them for forever
and that includes big drops big rises
just buy the assets and just become an
asset collector but with that said i
will keep more cash uh on hand uh during
times where it could be somewhat
tumultuous and it's just because it just
gives me kind of peace of mind it's
actually not that great of an economic
argument um it's just trying to get
peace of mind and not have to worry
about anything but that's really the
only change that i would have is just a
little bit more cash um and then all
right we'll do one more question please
ask the question here uh
what's been your favorite part of being
a dad um of course my wife asked me this
uh
and i'm getting messages that polina is
requesting you answer her question
my favorite part of being a dad by far
is that uh i get the combination of one
seeing my young daughter uh kind of go
through uh um kind of all these
different phases of at first she can't
recognize me then she can recognize me
then she knows the smile when she sees
me then she gets fascinated uh with
various things or toys and you can see
kind of the the cognitive development
is really cool
but at the same time i balance that with
at the same time that i'm watching my
daughter go through all that development
and you can just tell that uh she's kind
of
becoming more alert becoming more aware
of her surroundings she's learning she's
going through all of that
i joke all the time with my wife
that somehow my dad has gotten smarter
and smarter uh over the years my dad
used to tell me all the time uh that as
you get older i'll get smarter uh and
that's very true uh both for my dad and
my mom uh in that when you're a kid uh i
think it takes you having a kid to learn
more kind of about what the sacrifices
your parents went through and the things
that they did for you uh and so once you
learn that stuff uh you realize like man
i'm having a ton of fun as a dad
but at the same time i am uh more
thankful for my parents and everything
that they did for me so i think that's
probably uh the best answer hey you did
you like this video great we make five
of them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time